日本プロ盛り
jリーグに所属する松本山雅fc のホームタウン
松本は
四方を美しい山上で囲まれ
町の中心には
筑女400有余年の歴史を刻む
国宝松本城がそびえ立っております
街のランドマークとして
市民に親しまれてきたこの松本城もう
今から百数十年前取り壊しの危機に晒されました
そんな中
松本から松本城を失ってしまえば松本らしさが失ってしまうと
1館
良三さんはじめ多くの市民が
全国を駆け回り資金を上達した上で
と陸は初球を出したと聞いております
自分たちの街は自分たちで作るという
市民運動が息づくこの松本に
まだ改む
多くの市民が参画をし
一人ひとりの手で作り上げてきたああ
死人クラブ松本山雅fc
日本のサッカー界の頂点のリーグに当たる j d 2昇格を果たしました
このプロジェクトが発足した当時は
壮大な夢に向かって挑戦する事は非常に大切なことである
今から jリーグなんて無理な話ではないか
そんな意見が
大半を占めるだか
やり続けることによって夢は現実のものとなりました
松本山雅fc の jリーグへ向けてのプロジェクト
夢は必ず叶うというお話を始めさせていただきます
今から
ちょうど50年前の1965年に
松本の池前にあった
喫茶店やまがで産声をあげました
喫茶店のマスターである
山下さんの厚意により
一つのサッカーボールと
日本が
店に来るお客さんにプレゼントされたというのが
きっかけで山がクラブが誕生するわけでございますけれども
最初の頃は
サッカーケンケン者がほとんどいないというリクレーション的なチームでありました
次第に高校時代サッカーを経験した人たちの集まりだして競技志向へのクラブと進化し
ていきます
時には試合当日
新調した日本を
にそれを通そうとしますと胸に流れた
山に土産の山雅の文字が間違っするというハプニングもあったというふうに聞いており
ますけれども
その後次第にその場が広がり
1975年に発足した
北信越リーグの
3戦とともに
活躍し40年経った2005年からこのチームを核とした
jada のプロジェクトが発足するのです
サッカー不毛の長野県に何と言っても jリーグのこのプロジェクトが立ち上がった
きっかけとなったのが
2001年松本市にある人ができたというのが非常に大きな要因となっております
2万人収容のスタジアムは j 1規格のスタジオので
ピッチとスタンドとの距離が非常に近い
素晴らしいスタジアムです
そしてその翌年2002年に日韓ワールドカップが開催され
この松本のある意味において
南米パラグアイナショナルチームのキャンプ地として使用をされたのです
そんな中
パラ-なるチームのある選手が記者会見で
松本にはこんなに素晴らしいスタジアムがあるのに
地元のプロサッカーチームがないなんてのは不思議だと言う
ごめん投資
それに地域の若者たちが
さらに jリーグへの期待を膨らませるのです
結果的には2005年のシーズンから北施設のに日からスタートし幾多の困難を
乗り越え
7年かかって2011年12月12日2月昇格を果たすのでありますが
2005年発足当時の
我はみたいな親が子のない市民クラブのスタートというのは何もないところからも
スタートでした
後ろの画像が最初の時の事務局です
知り合いのボランティア団体の
一角を間借りし
1台のパソコン3台の机に常勤のボランティアスタッフ1人のスタートでした
練習環境も
夜7時から9時までの2時間の練習でしたけれども
土のグラウンドはもとより
照明が暗い中での練習ということで選手も相当苦労したと思います
そして後ろの試合は練習試合の時の映像ですけども
お揃いのユニフォームも育っていない
そして遠征の時などは我々の次回お仕上げ
分譲して遠征するなどこのチームは本当に jリーグに昇格できるのかとそんな不安も
よぎったのも非常に思い出となりますが
1年1円成長しサポーターの間もどんどん広がっていきました
そんな中いろんな人との出会いだ
そのスピードをさらに加速させそしてその輪をさらに広げです
広げるのです
何人かのキーマンを紹介させていただきたいと思いますけれども
この中にも
その何かのだっさーたちがいるんですけども
今日はちょっと時間の関係で3人ほどご紹介をさせていただきたいと思います
後ろの写真は実際に2002年
松本山雅の試合の時のサポーターの写真です
真ん中にいる疋田さん
俺が一番最初に松本山雅のサポーてターンになるという宣言し
現在も松本山雅の核となるサポーター団体
ultras 松本の代表をやってる疋田さんです
そしてもう一型
jリーグに昇格すれば試合運営には上がらずボランティアが必要だ
俺は今からその準備を始めると宣言し
ボランティア団体チームばボスを立ち上げた代表の田中さん
自分たちの楽しさを周りの仲間に伝えながらその仲間がさらに周りの仲間を歩いへと
誘ったのです
その成果は
こちらは2003年のゴール裏のサポーターの画像ですけども
このしかいなかったサポーターが
このような形で素晴らしい盛り上がりになり
歩いがマインの状態に立ったのです
一朝一夕でこのようになっただけではなく継続することの大切さとそして何よりも
自分たちが楽しく楽しみながらやった結果このように広がりが
見えてきたと思います
我々のサポーターは
お年寄りからお子さんまで幅広い年代のサポーターが都度アットホーム的な
サポーターが多いです
そして親も3台で絆が深まる
スタジアムとしてそういったことが我々のクラブの一番の自慢であると思いますがそう
いった雰囲気になったというのも疋田さん田中さんの思いをはじめから踏襲している
証しではないでしょうか
もう1型
横浜 f マリノスで16年間活躍し
jf 時代2011年松本山雅に du 直しました
元日本代表松田直樹選手
俺が松本山の泡が必ず
実に昇格させるそして松本全国にすると宣言し
大黒柱の活躍として活躍を
いたした次第でございますけれども
残念ながら
8月2日
練習中に心筋梗塞で倒れ
ついに8月4日帰らぬ人となってしまいました
彼の死後も
選手が一丸となり
彼の家約束したぜー数昇格に向けて一生懸命戦い
最終戦の混戦を制し
12月4日次に j 2昇格を果たしました
今まで携わってきた山がはめりとともにこの悲願の j 2昇格を喜びそして天国に
いる
マツダ now 選手にこの報告をの一番させていただきました
あれはなくなった今でも我々の心の中に生き続け
共に闘っているでしょう
いつの日母の待つ違う選手のつけていた背番号3番
これに憧れる地域の子供たちが家がのトップチームに昇格することを期待してやみませ
ん
松本山雅の運営会社
株式会社松本山雅の企業理念は
未来へのイベと感動へチャレンジでございます
我々の目標は j 1でしょ
1位になること優勝することというのは目標ではなく
歩いに訪れた人たちに夢や希望感動を支えるというのが一番
使命だというふうに思います
そういう意味では2014年 j 1に昇格した
その年の最終戦にこのような形である院で j 1昇格のお祝いお魚
サポーターのみなさんが
1万5千本の紙テープで祝福して頂いたのです
この瞬間こそが我々の目的の達成であり今後さらにこの場を広げて聞きたい
そんな風に考えています
街の中で行われた j バー昇格パレードにも5万人近い市民の方が駆けつけて
いただき
松本らしさを演出する意味でも
地元のお祭りの舞台に選手が乗り込みお城までパレードさせていただきました
松本城で行われた j 1昇格報告会にも1万人近いサポーターの皆さんとこの喜びを
分かち合えたというふうに思います
クラブは
2012年に jリーグに昇格した際
未来の成長戦略と題しまして
海外の
先進事例を学ぶべく
ドイツに社員全員を派遣しドイツの分冊リーガーの先進事例を学びました
天井経営を続けながらこのホームタウンと共に成長する
そして
地域の子供たちがトップチームに昇格できるような育成書式の確立を目指す
安全団真雅スタジアムを想像しながら
より快適なスタジアム環境を作るというのが大きな
勉強の成果でありますけどもまさにそれを今後実践していくということでございます
そしてそんな研修の際に1人のサポーターの放った言葉が今でも私の胸に残っている
ことを御紹介させていただきたいと思います
後ろの方は
ドイツの南西部フライブルクにある sc フライブルクのサポーターの1人です
松本と同じ規模の24万人の年のサポートでクラブのサポーターですけども
そのサポーターの1人が
オリザ氏のフライブルクはドイツで一番素晴らしい地域なんだ
その素晴らしい地域に
小さくて予算規模も少ないのによく頑張った
クラム c フラグループがある
俺はこの25年間
シーズンパス券を買い続けながら
このクラブとともに携わってきた
この後も将来
このブランドと共に闘っていくんだとおっしゃってました
いつの日か我々もこのようなサポーターが増えるそんな愛されるクラブを目指してこれ
からも頑張って参りたいと思います
松本山雅は1965年創立ということで
本年で50周年の節目の年を迎えます
先ほどご紹介ありましたとおりん
我々のルーツは喫茶店だったということを考えますと
いつの日か
喫茶山雅を復活して
そこに集まる人たちが美味しいコーヒーを飲みながら
松本山雅のサッカーが海に肌を咲かせる
こんな姿も想像していきたいそのように考えておりますし
これからの50年100年続く成長できるクラブとしてあるためにも
喫茶店のマスター山下さんの思いや
きたさん高さという想いを大切にしながら
もっと成長できるクラブにしていくためにクラブとしては
大切に考えていることがあります
それは
今までもそしてこれからも山がリサイズされるすべての人たちが
私利私欲なく
地域の発展とクラブの成長を願うということを忘れてはいけないのです
そして
サッカースタジアムは唯誕サッカーを観る場所ではなく
夢劇場という意識を忘れてはいけません
松本山雅のスタジアムは山劇場であり
1人のサポーター一人のボランティアがその山が月曜に実践している
主人公ということを忘れてはいけないのです
今までも自分たちが作ってきた
クラブという自信こそがこの松本山雅の
この大きくなった成長のところに現れているというふうに思いますし
こういったことこそが真凛クラブにできるアイディアだというふうに思います
一人の起業家
一つの企業へ一人のリーダーシップを取った人たちではこういったことができません
神の市民クラブであるためにこういったことはせずに今後も成長していきたいとおもい
ます
松本山雅はこれからもいくつかの夢に向かって挑戦をしてきます
さの一つに
松本町の南真ん中に新しいスタジアムを建設したい
そんな夢があります
これはサッカーの試合をやるというだけのスタジアムにだのはダーク
松本の街の中をにぎわいを創造するという意味で非常に大切なものだという風に考えて
いる
しかしながらこの夢の現実実現には相当なパワーのいることでしょう
しかしながら
必ずこの夢を達成しています見せます
夢に向かって挑戦している時が人生の中で一番楽しい時だということを我々はわかり
始めたからです
一つの力が合わされば大きな力に変化することがみんなが分かり始めてきました
ほとばしる情熱やひたむきに保守た行動が合わされば
この街の明るい未来を必ず
想像できると信じておりません
今までもそしてこれからも
山がファミリーとともに
心をひとつに共に戦ってまいります
松本や柄のジェリー名のプロジェクト
夢は必ず叶うというお話を終わらせていただきますご静聴ありがとうございました